- Sometimes, people want creamier things,
and sometimes, people want
like a
- Oh.
- Is it good?
Did you get that?
I almost heard like, "Oh,
(beep), this is good."
- Oh, (beep), this is good.
(grooving R&B music)
- Hi, it's Tiffany Young.
I have Evan here, because he wants
to get to like ice cream.
- I've never had any like, good
ice cream before in my life.
I just don't like sweet stuff.
- I'm losing it right now.
Did he just say, "I
don't like sweet things?"
Everybody watching is judging you hard.
- We're gonna be going to some of the
highest rated ice cream places
in L.A., according to Yelp.
- So, yeah, I am an ice cream fanatic.
I like all the ice cream stores,
'cause I have a favorite at each store.
So it's like, "Okay, I'm feeling like,
"Cap'n Crunch ice cream today.
"What kind of Cap'n Crunch ice cream?"
I am your ice cream bible.
(soft jazz music)
We are now at our first
location: Milk Ice Cream Parlor.
They're very famous for
their ice cream macarons.
- Macaroons?
Is that how you pronounce it, macaroons?
- It's not a oo, it's like a macaron.
- Macarons.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- I think I have some
street cred with macarons.
Another famous piece, Red Velvet cookies,
Fruity Pebble cookies, you can
create an ice cream sandwich.
One of my favorite ice
cream are the Thai Tea.
- Thai Tea's great.
I always get the banana split.
- Banana split?
I mean, come on, there's like, Nutella,
Coffee Toffee, Blood Orange
sorbet, Mint and Chip,
Lime sorbet, Thai Tea, you name it,
and you wanna go for the banana split?
- Do you own this place?
- I know, I can work here.
- I wanna try the sandwich.
- Okay.
- You don't recommend?
Your face tells me.
- Oh, 'cause think about it.
It's like, would you
want Thai Tea with like,
Fruity Pebbles, and like,
you know what I mean?
You have to be smart.
- Okay.
(they laugh)
- Am I like, mind boggling?
- I like mint, too.
- I love mint chip, but just like honesty,
it just tastes like toothpaste.
- It might be a little weird,
but I like the taste of toothpaste.
So, Red Velvet and Red Velvet?
- Uh huh.
- Isn't that too
overpowering, no?
- [Tiffany] Mmm.
- [Evan] I guess not.
- The texture.
- Yeah.
- [Tiffany] If you like chewy cookies.
- Mmm.
- See?
He said he don't like sweets. (laughs)
It's not that sweet.
- It's not that sweet,
that's why it's so good.
- Mmm, this is my absolute favorite.
I mean, who doesn't like Fruity Pebbles?
If you don't like Fruity
Pebbles, I question you.
Kendrick Lamar likes Fruity Pebbles.
- Well, I'm not Kendrick Lamar. (laughs)
I like this better.
Too much flavor going on here, for me.
- When you're feeling extra, and then,
when you want just like, the original.
- When you want the OG stuff,
(Tiffany laughs)
you should get this.
This Thai Tea's great.
I was never imagining Thai
Tea with an ice cream,
as an ice cream.
- What?
- You always drink it as a tea.
- [Tiffany] I would put it on the inside.
- Like, what do you mean?
- Like, the bottom, cause it's flat.
Come on.
(they giggle)
(mid-tempo jazz music)
- [Evan] We are here at Somisomi.
- In K-Town, represent.
It's my first time here.
- Do you like soft serves?
- Yes, I do.
- So you can choose whether
you want it on bungeoppang.
- I don't think these viewers
know what bungeoppang is.
- B-rolls.
(jazzy piano music)
- Okay.
- Okay, yup.
Yup, there we go.
- I like how he does that.
And you can pick your fillings?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
You can choose Red Bean,
Custard, and Nutella.
This is like, the prettiest sprinkles.
This is like, it looks like Gucci.
(Tiffany and Evan laugh)
It's so good, I ate half of it while
we were sitting back down.
- Wanna try Matcha?
- [Tiffany] Yes.
That's really good.
- It's pretty deep, huh?
- But it's not like, too heavy,
where it's the tea and it
makes your throat kinda hurt.
- I think for Black Sesame, it's
like organic, is what I heard.
It's not like artificial black sesame,
it's a real like, yeah.
- Oh cool.
I think Black Sesame has
a specific following.
People like--
- It's either you like it
- Like it or you don't,
- or yeah, you don't.
- and people who like it
search for really good places with it.
- Try the filling.
- [Tiffany] Mmm, mmm.
- Oh, that's so good.
- There's no way.
- [Evan] Guilty pleasure, for sure.
- I have my makeup
artist, she's like, "No!
"Eat pretty."
(soft jazz piano music)
We are finally at Salt
& Straw on Larchmont.
I bring my band mates here all the time.
Not only do they have really, really fancy
and sophisticatedly crafted flavors,
they have a monthly flavor.
- [Evan] Ooh.
- What I love about going to Salt & Straw
is that when you come out, your hair
smells like waffle cones.
(Evan laughs)
You feel very, very like cute.
- I am ready to feel cute after.
- And like a waffle cone?
- Yeah.
- That's fabulous.
- Can I try.
- Do you wanna try Honey Lavender as well?
That's one of their
like, signature flavors.
Doesn't it taste like a
really, really good hand soap?
(laughs)
I got the Birthday Cake and Blackberries.
- Which is the July special.
- Which is like
a July special.
There is a poll at the end of the year,
so that they can bring
back certain flavors.
- Oh really?
- I went hard on the Ginger Bread
Cookie Dough, and it never came back.
If y'all are watchin',
help me vote for this
Ginger Bread Cookie Dough
back for the summer.
- Support that flavor.
- This is like, the fun part of it,
and you really become a fan.
- [Evan] So, I got Honey Lavender.
- Which is a signature flavor here.
- I've never tasted anything like this.
This tastes exactly like how it smells,
if that makes sense.
- Which is great.
- Yeah.
Which is great.
Texture, and the flavor,
and the temperature,
everything's just like.
- Y'all getting this on camera?
He's a fan. (laughs)
- I think that was it.
There wasn't really
anybody that was just like,
all right, we gotta take
you to some ice cream store.
- Okay.
- Ice cream parlors, excuse me.
Have them try some bunch of stuff.
- Be experimental.
I don't think you can go wrong
with ice cream.
- Okay.
(soft jazz music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now, your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.